former Wales rugby captain Gareth Thomas
posted an emotional video on social
media yesterday saying he had been the
victim of a homophobic attack in his
hometown of Cardiff he said he was
encouraged by police to talk to his
teenager attacker rather than pressing
charges I want to say thank you to the
police who were involved and were very
helpful and allowed me to do restorative
justice with the people who did this
because I thought they could learn more
that way than any other way and also to
the people of Cardiff who supported me
and helped me
joining us now is Nigel Owens
international rugby referee and the
first openly gay man to referee at that
level he too chose to use restorative
justice after he was sent home a phobic
abuse on Twitter in 2015 hello - Nigel
thanks for joining us on the program
this afternoon I mean this was an
absolutely shocking attack against
Gareth um
how surprised are you that this sort of
offense continues I was surprised and
disappointed really when I when I hear
about it yesterday but but also as well
on the other hand I'm not really
surprised because I know a lot of people
a lot of people I speak to who will come
across and after being on Jeremy fine
show this afternoon about you know I've
got quite a few messages since then
about people telling me that they've
experienced the same thing so it is
something that is that is more common
than maybe we think it is or maybe more
common than we like to but they think it
is and particularly if it won't profile
and you're out and you're on it in
public as well especially for the Cara's
house I think you can become then more
of a target I believe and only honest
chicken something like this maybe to to
everybody choose to be aware and to
raise the awareness that but it is an
issue on and also not just an issue from
a homophobic point of view you know
because we are where we are gay also for
people from definite ethnic background
different color skin different religious
beliefs this is something a lot of
people have to put up with in every day
of their lives and it's something but
you shouldn't have to it doesn't matter
what your sexuality is your career skin
your religious beliefs
none of this should matter at all all
should matter is if you've a decent
human being that you should be treated
the same allowed to get on with your
life in society without the fear of
having to deal with issues like this
which is which is which is very very sad
Julian is a fear that people have to
live with myself and included and three
years ago you were a victim of
homophobic abuse weren't you it wasn't
physical but nevertheless it was
incredibly unpleasant
until it was brought to my attention by
the police got in touch with me it was
made aware to them and then to me by a
lot of people in social media who
reported this young person and it was
after as a referee you're instigating
abuse because if you can't even have
been chief you can't do the job and it
was after the England France came in
took and I'm in 2015 in the superstar 36
Nations game where this happened and but
it was it was quite personal and
unacceptable abuse as well and it was
brought to my attention with the police
and it was dealt with there then in the
same way the card is dealing with this
because the slight difference here maybe
and I had already know the battle was
happened to Gareth and Hounds come about
but the young person who was from my
area sent me a message on facebook the
day after profoundly apologizing for his
actions and saying it was a he was not
that type of person it was just a
drunken moment and he totally regrets it
and and the police said then that you
can deal with this in different ways
where he can be taken on which means
you'd have a criminal record if I'm
guilty and we should stay with him for
the rest of his life or they deal with
in the way that Caiaphas done know where
the priests will have a record of his
actions but he doesn't carry that record
around with him and because IIIi thought
he was sincere his apologies I agreed to
meet up with him and he could see that
he was sincere and apologetic for what
he had happen honey and in fact he was
he was a very decent young man and I
think this then was the best way to deal
with that now the issue or the problem
can be is there are some individuals out
there I'm not saying that this is the
case in Gardez case whatsoever but there
are some individuals out there who are
just nasty nasty people and sometimes by
getting away with something but you're
saying sorry they feel are we got away
with this now and there's not gonna be
any comebacks on me and you don't know
what type of person that is but in my
case this person was it was a genuine
person was genuine sorry I would would
have learned by that thunder and I think
that was a right way to deal it in a
young person who had just made a stupid
mistake at the time now not every case
is like that so it's up to the police
then unguarded to deal with this in in
the appropriate way that they think is
the best way absolutely a big man as you
were for agreeing that restorative
justice was the way
he was very brave to come out when he
did back in it was some years ago now is
now I can't remember the exact year are
you surprised
though Nigel's that so few elite sports
personalities and sports men and women
have come out so since that happened and
there were some suggestions that
potentially that would open the
floodgates and more people who are elite
sports personalities would feel that
okay you know what he's done that I feel
comfortable enough to do the same but it
just hasn't happened has it we must look
is in my case I mean God has casein
issues were similar in my case you know
I was dealing my sexuality I I was
becoming somebody I didn't want to be I
didn't know nothing about being gay I
was 19 20 20 years ago before I
experienced it and I was fighting
against it and put me in a very very
dark place and the only way that I
accepted my sexuality at 26 years of age
was that I've tried to take my own life
one night and I'm landed up in a
hospital in intensive care for a couple
of days and you know that on the doctor
said another 20 minutes I mean too late
to save you and my mom and people came
to visit and my mum said to me look if
you ever do anything like that again
then and you may as well take me and and
your dad with you because we don't want
to live our life without you and you
know that's something that I have to
live with for the rest of my life but
that is where I accepted my sexuality
because I had that second chance so a
lot of people are dealing with a
sexuality
I'm trying exactly themselves so until
they can accept it themselves they are
not able then to come out and be
themselves but also as well which goes
hand in hand is when the environment is
not accepting you know with all rugby
and I'm sure all the other sports
including football or something comes
out in football will accept and we see
that or the message to support that
Gareth has had over the last 24 48 hours
has been massive massive majority of
support but when you have things like
this rising the head it does hinder
people who are scared of coming out
because they are worried how people are
going to perceive them
and how are they going to be able to get
on with your life because there is no
doubt about it that your life is more
difficult I think and this is this is
proven that you know and what we want is
to see that the majority people are
supportive and that these sort of nasty
people are in the minority but there is
too much of the minority at the moment
and we just need to make that less and
less and less so I think it's quite a
few reasons why people do not come out
and I think this is not helping the
reason where people are still thinking
oh look we're still not safe to come out
because we've just seen a Welsh legend
dandelions legend and Kapteyn just being
you know beaten up on on the weekend and
for asexuality which is which is totally
totally unacceptable and that is
something that nobody should have to put
up with where is your sexuality your
colour of your skin your religious
beliefs you come from a different
country you should to live your life
the same way as everybody else of the
respected entry what is everybody else
good to talk to you thanks so much Andy
for taking the time we do appreciate it
thank you